i think this is where i want to go i
can't believe you know where you're
going i never can understand how to get
well then why don't you
shut up and enjoy the ride
i looked at you and i knew you wanted an
egg
did you see my adam sandler interview
kevin neela dude
people told me that you fanned out so
bad this is how much
i love you this is how much i love burke
kreitzer when you when you were like
this
hang on a second hang on adam hang on a
second i have a story
i have a story i want to tell dude the
me too movement has killed the [ __ ]
my wife will not suck my dick on her
knees ever again
never will happen because your stomach
is pushing down her [ __ ] neck
her face is tilted back like this on her
forehead
it's like going down an eight-foot pool
down to the bottom and not clearing your
ears
i feel bad for your wife what do you do
we're doing it i don't understand why
they just can't word it like
so you can understand it
they always word it where like no means
yes yes means no or there's something
[ __ ] attached to it that's not in the
paragraph
i don't get any of that
you okay burt or yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah no i was gonna say we're doing uh
i don't want to do i don't want to talk
politics dude i [ __ ] hate talking
hey listen you [ __ ] i've tried
to say the same sentence four times
okay i'm sorry jesus christ and then
when i i gave you time you're like what
per where i'm going to talk and i was
going to do it again
and you stuck up me up again
well just tell me to shut up what's
what's what's the flaw that knee has
that you love
my wife is [ __ ] gorgeous but what's a
flaw she has a [ __ ] jlo body dude
she's [ __ ] gorgeous but what's the
flaw
that you see in her sometimes and you go
but now i love it
physical then anything
she can't be without oh no yeah her
[ __ ]
uh yeah personality [ __ ]
you're gonna get me in trouble here
how do you pronounce the word
c-e-m-e-n-t
c-e-m-e-n-t
cement cement cement
hey let me tell you something you keep
talking wise you're going to end up with
a pair of cement shoes
i thought that's right that's how they
see it
i didn't know that i lived i lived with
two lesbians in new york
and i i was fresh out of college i
didn't know anything about
anything oh god diverse and can i watch
you two get it on
while i have my shirt off what did i say
and then i come on your face
no that's not cool
i paid half my rent technically why am i
paying half if you [ __ ] you should be
a third to third
if i'm paying fifty percent i gotta be
able to see the two you go down on each
other
and then they flipped out
i pronounce word i pronounce a lot of
words wrong but like i think it's i
i like i i always say miss mess
massa like i get i get a massage
it's a massage massager
a massage massage
massage oh okay there you go how do you
say
you ready for this b-u-f-f-e-t
buffet buffet
buffet no you don't you're trying to get
you're gonna get your ass kicked
hey let's walk across the cement over to
the buffet
i am on the wagon bill december 1st
all dry december no booze going
pescetarian
i'm cleaning my life no cigars i'm going
healthy bill i got to tell you something
man that's
and that's commendable because that's
that's one of the one of the hardest
times is that a beer
i thought that was a guinness you just
poured i was like oh my god i walked
into a bit what is that
it's an iced coffee dude that would have
been the greatest setup ever and
i'm singing your phrases you just bust
out of
black and tan whatever the hell that
looked like for
exactly 619 000 right there you're right
on the corner
you've got coffee corn coin laundry
that's amazing about l.a it's like
breastfeeding
oh there you go huh we got we got to
support that right
yep what did you do if i rolled down the
window and you saw this whole
conservative side of me hey
take that inside take it inside
i don't have to look at that english
english o-n-i-o-n
you got to go slower dude i'm too dumb
[Laughter]
it was just a lot of o's in that i
didn't know where you were going o-n-i
oh joe rogan
o n i o n you cut one and they make oh
yeah yeah yeah
now you're in my head because this seems
so easy onion
uh on an onion onion
i'm calling [ __ ] you're just [ __ ]
with me no it's a-n-a-h-n-i-o-n
so it's onion onion where you go where
did you get this sandwich
right down on the corner this italian
place and i was nervous when i walked in
because there was nobody in there
and they were playing frank sinatra
music and i was like they're trying too
hard
i mean they already got the red and
white you know
he doesn't something and she does this
she's got a big [ __ ] that i'm gonna kiss
it's the 1940s i'll leave her on the
side of the road
i can still hit her she talks back yeah
i love this neighborhood because it's
closer to the airport and that guy's
scratching his balls with [ __ ]
extension cord did you just see that
that guy was just full-on
raking his pubes
uh you know that people wrote articles
on your special paper tiger
you know people paper line you know that
people got
paid to do what
it was paper tiger i like paper line
better paper line was the name of the
book right
i don't know but i love paper lion isn't
that crazy wait a minute hey we gotta
[Laughter]
pay for lion i think that's gonna be
that's gonna be the part two
yeah dude you are my favorite comedian i
love paper lion
thank you
[Music]
here's a good one here's a good one okay
how do you pronounce pronunciation
it's this is how you this is the proper
this is really a fun [ __ ] so this is
do you see that bill yeah you pronoun
it's not
pronunciation pronunciation it's pronoun
pronunciation no no you're you're you're
getting too far into the sound spell
it's pronunciation
pronunciation let's not pronounce ca
sean
pronunciation yeah don't you doing that
he's doing it adam sandler occasion man
wait would your would your wife get
upset
if she saw you looking at like asian
czech porn
no what if it was white chick porn no so
you can
you can like float all the boundaries
she understands that
porno is not a real person no i think my
wife
if it was like asian chicks my wife
would be like what's up with that
like she'd want me to be looking at porn
that looks like she's a white
supremacist
porn person yeah they really did own
slaves
the callback bam that's how it works
people
the two interviews are h3h3 and theo
vaughn
where everyone's like did you see that
interview and by the way
knowing you i don't see anything wrong
with the interview i had a great time on
the theo vaughn thing i don't know what
the [ __ ] happened with that
i don't know we had a good time i'd
showed him my truck we had a great
[ __ ] time i thought you guys had a
great time i thought it was a great
interview i think it is
i knowing both of you you were not not
you and he was not not him
yeah and that's the thing i'll do his
podcast again and the thing about it is
is
we i i understand his vibe more yeah so
it's just
it's tough to gel with and like if
you're completely
in the dark of what you're doing you it
takes you a second to like
to like double dutches it's one of my
favorite comics he is
yeah i don't know so like people like to
take a little [ __ ] thing
and then gas it up and make it something
else and then it becomes
like you know that's all they're doing
that's like what's funny is the average
douchebag on these [ __ ] social medias
is no different
than these giant corporate news agencies
where they're just they're just
taking [ __ ] out of context to cause you
to cause
something that didn't even happen so
you'll stop and watch it
so they can make money off of views yeah
and and people
on the internet do the exact same thing
they know exactly where to cut it
where to begin it and where to end it to
make it to take it from a level two
up to [ __ ] 12. i watched you and
theo's whole interview
didn't find anything wrong with it
including what what people will say is
how it ended which is you going i have
to go i have to leave now yeah
my kid was getting up it had nothing to
do with him and and but when
then i watched the uh uh you you got to
see this interview with bill and theo
and they chop it up to make it look like
you don't like him you don't get him do
they do that with rogan where they'll do
like his reaction that guy ready
and they can they totally make a
completely different interview that
didn't even happen
oh yeah don't you have to tell me about
that yeah [ __ ] about all my
interviews yeah so
why why would you watch that [ __ ] i
don't i don't i watch it i watch it but
i don't know you but
that doesn't [ __ ] you bert
they're gonna cut this up now